à
[Musique]
dans un appart du monde l'afrique et en
australie par exemple le climat peut
être très sec
tellement sec que les feux de brousse
sont monnaie courante et comme ce serait
dommage de laisser passer une bonne
opportunité
nombreux sont les animaux et les plantes
qui profite et fabrose pour se
reproduire ou se mettre quelque chose
sous la dent
mais saviez vous qu'il existe des
oiseaux qui mettent volontairement le
feu non content de simplement profiter
ils répandent les flammes à droite et à
gauche et provoque ainsi de véritables
feux de forêt aujourd'hui nous allons
parler des oiseaux pyromanes
[Musique]
alors on va commencer par une petite
mise au point avant d'aller plus loin
les oiseaux dont nous parlons
aujourd'hui sont incapables de créer du
feu eux mêmes un ils n'ont ni à l'hiver
ni briquet il se contente de répondre
les flammes en utilisant des branches
déjà enflammé en un sens ils font
qu'aggraver une situation qui est
vraiment mal engagée alors pas au sens
où l'entend humainement parlant
mais répondre tout de même
volontairement le feu et ça elle va ça
rentre aussi dans la définition d'un
pyromane mise alors qui sont ces oiseaux
qui répandent des incendies et surtout
pourquoi font-ils cela
[Musique]
où elle expliqué il va falloir remettre
les choses dans leur contexte
et tout d'abord direction l'australie où
vivent ces charmantes bestioles qui
romane
[Musique]
l'australie est planté d'une végétation
bien particulière composée de nombreuses
essences pour lesquels le feu n'est pas
réellement un problème
le climat chaud et sec de la majeure
partie de l'australie est en effet
propice aux feux de brousse et les
plantes ont dû s'adapter aux incendies
très fréquents on parle de plantes pirro
fit pierrot au feu et fit aux plantes
non non on s'en fiche pas annoncer ça
fait partie de l'écosystème
ça montre que les espèces dans cet
endroit sont adaptés au feu on peut pas
parler des animaux sans parler des
plantes qui y sont liés c'est un tout
parmi les adaptations des plantes qui
profite on trouve une écorce très
épaisse pour résister aux flammes
des bons jours cachés sous les corses
pour pouvoir repousser tout de suite une
fois que le feu est passé en habillement
les corses un peu comme chez le khalife
tus par exemple un système racinaire
très développée comme des rhizomes au
pouvoir repoussé facilement après un feu
d arbres avec des branches très haute
pour éviter que le feu ne les atteignent
comme le pin parasol ou encore des
graines qui ne peuvent germer qu'une
fois que le fun a ouverte ou en à
stimuler la croissance
les animaux ne sont pas en reste non
plus et nombreux sont les espèces à
avoir développé des comportements
appropriés comme se réfugier dans le
premier tie venu que ce soit le leur ou
non ou bien se diriger vers les zones
déjà consumée par le feu ou ils ne
risqueront plus grand chose et dans le
cas de certains prédateurs attendre
tranquillement à côté d'une zone
enflammé que les proies leur saute
littéralement dans les griffes
[Musique]
alors en ce qui concerne les oiseaux
on note à ce jour trois espèces de
rapaces capable non seulement d'utiliser
les feux de brousse comme moyen de se
remplir le japon mais aussi de répandre
ses feux pour augmenter leurs chances
d'attraper quelque chose il s'agit du
milan noir du milan siffleur et du
faucon bérigaud rend le milan noir est
passé connu en europe on le voit rentrer
tous les printemps pour la saison de
nidification
ils passent l'hiver dans le site de
l'afrique ou en australie ce sont de
grandes roses emprunt font c'est qu'ils
ont la particularité d'avoir la queue en
v et comme tous les mille ans ils se
déplacent souvent en groupe
le milan siffleur est un peu moins
commun car on le trouve qu en australie
et sur les îles proches
il a inscrit très spécial qui permet de
le reconnaître à coup sûr d'où son nom
enfin le petit faucon bigorra et tours 1
avec de longues pattes d'une moustache
noire sur la phase i et comme le milan
siffleur il ne dit qu en australie
c'est trois espèces sont ce que l'on
appelle des espèces opportuniste car
elle mange un peu tout ce qui leur tombe
sous la serre sans distinction allant
parfois jusqu à consommer des carcasses
d'animaux bien plus grand calme
alors lorsque l'occasion se présente
oui mais au contraire des vautours il
sait aussi chasser
d'ailleurs ils sont aussi opportuniste
dans d'autres domaines que
l'alimentation
car dans le cas du milan siffleur et du
faucon bérigaud race ce sont des espèces
qui ne construisent pas leurs propres
lits il utilise des vieux ni d'autres
oiseaux qu'ils aménagent à leur
convenance
oui ou bien des espèces particulièrement
intelligente qui sait car il existe
beaucoup de prédateurs qui utilisent le
feu comme moyen d'attraper plus de proie
de nombreuses espèces de carnivores sont
même attiré par le feu comme les chats
domestiques par exemple et en un sens et
c'est logique l'odeur de fumée c'est la
promesse d'un bon gueuleton
mais il n'existe que très peu d'espèces
capable de mettre volontairement le feu
à une nouvelle zone de fourrés et c'est
en cela que ces trois espèces de rapaces
sont assez exceptionnelles mais comment
font-ils pour répandre le feu tout
simplement en prenant des bras ni
enflammé dans leur sert donc leurs
griffes et en les amenant plus loin là
où le feu n'a pas encore mangé la
végétation mais ils attendent
tranquillement proximité que le feu
prenne dans ce nouvel endroit efface
s'envoler les insectes et fuir les
petits mammifères et ensuite et by ap
qu'à servir derrière de l'agilité
naturel des milans envol leur donne
beaucoup d'efficacité dans la traque et
la capture de ces profs fuyant le font
grâce alors que enlevé et leur longueur
ils sont capables d'acrobaties aériennes
assez formidable la forme de leurs que
ressemble un peu à celle des hirondelles
par exemple qui elles aussi font
d'incroyables figures aériennes et des
changements de direction en plein vol
alors c'est très utile lorsqu'on
poursuit de gros insectes par exemple et
qu'il faut être très vif
[Musique]
le problème principal vient du fait que
les mille ans par exemple sont capables
de transporter ces brindille enflammé
sur un bon kilomètre largement de quoi
passer outre les coupes et naturels
comme les rivières où les routes et
c'est donc un gros problème pour les
pompiers parce qu'ils essaient de
protéger certaines zones
pire encore s'ils ne font pas attention
les oiseaux peuvent allumer un feu
derrière eux et les enfermés au centre
d'un cercle de flammes
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire l'autre
problème c'est qu'il ne s'agit pas
seulement de quelques oiseaux qui ont ce
comportement des dizaines et des
dizaines de milan se regroupent autour
d'un feu et transportent chacun des
branches à droite et à gauche aliments
ainsi une myriade de nouveaux foyers
tout autour et ainsi de suite
la zone brûlée finale est donc largement
plus étendue que ce qu'elle aurait pu
l'être sans intervention à vienne et
comme le gouvernement australien ne
prend toujours pas en compte ce problème
dans la prise en charge des feux de
forêt c'est pas étonnant que les feux de
brousse pas jusqu'à une dizaine de morts
par an rien qu'en australie
oui les feux de forêt de 2020 ont fait
35 morts au total ces trois à quatre
fois plus que la normale mais vu que
l'étendue des dégâts étaient énormes
plus de 18 millions d'hectares quand
même c'est pas étonnant oui il
semblerait que oui même si les
conditions climatiques étaient
particulièrement problématique en 2019
et 2020 avec beaucoup moins de pluie que
d'habitude et donc une végétation
extrêmement sèche mais c'est vrai que
ces oiseaux n'ont pas non plus arrangé
les choses
car dès que les mille ans transportait
une brindille enflammé le feu prenait
aussitôt dans les herbes sèches et paf
un nouveau foyer il faudrait commencer
par prendre en compte le danger que peut
représenter ces oiseaux vue qui peuvent
propager le feu au delà des coupe feux
habituel il est important de se prémunir
contre ce genre de problèmes autour des
agglomérations
alors peut-être en installant plus de
plan d'eau de bande pour les pompiers et
entraîné les équipes à ce genre de
scénario bref préparé le terrain en
quelque sorte et ça c'est le boulot du
gouvernement ensuite il faudrait
décourager la l'image de feu dans les
zones un peu plus sauvages comme les
feux de cambrai barbecue les aborigènes
qui vivent avec ces oiseaux depuis des
millénaires conseille de faire très
attention à nous
mais laisser un feu sans surveillance
pour lui et équins milan ou un faucon de
vienne récupérer un bout de bois
enflammés et ce particulièrement en
hiver les feux de forêt surviennent
d'habitude en étaient les feux qui se
déclenchent hors de la période
habituelle des feux donc en hiver
provoque beaucoup plus de dégâts que
ceux qui ont lieu en été tout simplement
parce que la végétation n'est pas prête
à se renouveler en hiver elle a évolué
avec certaines conditions
environnementales en l'occurrence des
feux de brousse en était il seulement si
l'incidence des feux change soudainement
ça va déstabiliser les écosystèmes
tessa et ça ne laissera pas le temps aux
écosystèmes de se renouveler alors en un
sens oui et c'est pas non plus la chose
à faire en supprimant les milan ont
détruit une partie de la chaîne
alimentaire d'un écosystème
ça amènera un déséquilibre et
possiblement à une prolifération de
leurs proies
non non c'est clairement pas une bonne
idée comme souvent il faut un équilibre
la nature australienne a besoin du feu
pour se renouveler elle a évolué ainsi
il ne faut pas supprimer totalement les
feux de forêt ils sont importants il
faut juste comprendre que c'est un cycle
il faut des feux intervalles réguliers
pour que c'était que système perdure
mais point trop n'en faut
en étudiant le rythme naturel des feux
de forêt les écosystèmes qui les
subissent nous comprenons petit à petit
comment tout cela fonctionne le fait que
ces trois espèces d'oiseaux mettre
volontairement le feu à des zones encore
non incendié n'a été publié dans une
revue scientifique à comité de lecture
quand 2018
on peut donc logiquement espérer que la
recherche progressera et quel avenir
nous serons plus apte à prendre les
bonnes décisions pour la pérennité des
espaces naturels qui nous entoure à
bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures avec
des plumes
[Musique]